what is it exactly it's pompeii covered
in ash after the volcanic eruption the
city is underneath the box i melted some
lego people and houses in a pot in my
stove
they're all dead
very
inventive
good luck
put this kid on some kind of watch list
terry
good to see you as always merry chisin
hall hello just doing my duty as a
history night sponsor
i trust that whatever disagreements we
have because of your actions we can
still deliver a cordial evening for the
kids kids come first today
any issues we have will play themselves
out through the courts
although anyone could see they're mostly
your fault
okay
well
i'm going to give a speech and after
that i'll thank the sponsors and allow
you to say a few words you'll allow me
well i'm the mayor well my casino
employs many of your constituents so
it's kind of like we're co-mayors
it's not like that even a little bit if
you'll excuse me
before i announce the winners of the
freshman and sophomore division i want
to say a few words about this town's
history which i know a little bit about
as the first black mayor of rutherford
falls
now i want to thank
all the generous sponsors who made this
night possible
who we unfortunately don't have time to
hear from
now every day i strive to make sure that
everyone in this town
thomas everyone
the ceo of the running thunder casino
who has his own microphone
many apologies i was hoping to do a
quick minishanka land acknowledgement
i'd like to take a moment to acknowledge
that we are currently standing
on minnesota land beautiful okay
mayor deirdre chisholm
all right
[Applause]
yo
what the hell terry you said my name
five times and i distinctly heard you
say genocide america has a troubled past
i think it's important to acknowledge
that we agreed to be civil i'm not the
one with the history of breaking
promises
fine fine great so great
okay what happened with these two i know
you know
i signed an nda and i can't tell you
but i will say if you're getting warm or
cold
is it a savings and alone thing they had
an affair they have a love child cult
[Music]
we reviewed your calendars and there's
45 events this year that you both rsvp'd
for so we think it's best you make peace
tonight now i don't know the details but
clearly there was some kind of betrayal
there were two betrayals one in the
kitchen and one in the jacuzzi i offered
to pay to fix it slumber said the what
your brother did in my jacuzzi was the
most horrific thing he'd ever seen and
he served in afghanistan no this is a
housing issue airbnb
i rented a casita from terry from my
brother's visit and there was some
damage to the property he threw up in
the skimmer
then used every kitchen tea towel to
clean it and when i tried to address the
problem directly this teacher's pet
insisted we'd go through the website you
have any idea what it feels like to lose
super host status it's humiliating i
have no idea what it feels like to own
an investment property i'm just a small
town man and as the first black mayor in
rutherford falls is that what you were
going to say you just can't see a world
in which you could have overreacted
you're stubborn you're completely unable
to listen to reason
oh
so i'm the angry black woman now that's
not what i said even if you're still mad
at me it's no reason to undermine me at
every turn besides slanderous minnesota
land acknowledgements what other tricks
do you plan to pull oh so now i'm the
tricky shifty indian i didn't even know
that was a thing oh it's a thing
[Music]
you